ven pasa pasa pasa pasa pasa pasa pasa
pasa pasa pasa
alors comment ça se passe pour l'instant
pour l'équipe de France très bien ça se
passe très bien on est on est bien placé
pour le moment on gère bien la course la
technique de course est est bien étudiée
on respecte les les consignes pour le
moment tout va bien comment ça se gère
une une course d'endurance notamment
aujourd'hui avec un terrain très lourd
et beaucoup de chevaux en compétition
alors justement c'est un petit peu le le
le problème parce qu'on est on connaî
pas trop le niveau vu que des les chevau
viennent de toutes les nations et on
connait pas le niveau des autres nations
forcément mais là justement comme les
cavalier français essaie de rester un
petit peu plus derrière pour pour pour
garder le plus de fraîcheur possible des
terrains très grass comme ça sont très
très exigeants donc oui les Français en
tout cas restent toujours un petit peu
plus en retrait pour pour garder le plus
de réserves et le plus d'énergie
possible pour les les fin de course qui
peuvent être très rapidees et
éventuellement reprendre du temps sur
les fins de parcours quand les premiers
peut-être faibliront un petit peu c'est
ce qu'on espère en tout cas pour
l'équipe de France ça va être une course
par élimination en
fait vu vu l'état du terrain oui alors
normalement non mais c'est vrai que vu
l'état du terrain ça peut être voilà
devant il peut y avoir un peu des
chevaux qui craquent et des des des des
des défaillances un petit peu physiques
l'équipe de France veut
surtout garder et préserver la
l'intégrité physique des chevaux et
c'est ça le plus important avant de de
de vraiment avant la compétition la
compétition est très importante mais
voilà on fait vraiment très attention au
physique et à l'intégrité physique des
chevix y